déjà c'est un bonheur pour nous de voir
comme ça parce que je te trouve pas je
te trouve bien la tête était magnifique
mais grâce à quai grâce à trois merci
moyenne et à toute son équipe je tenais
à tous à vous dire
deux eaux et tout franchement quand je
suis avec vous belge et la joie ça me
donne envie d'être avec vous en faites
et c'est vrai que toi tu as vécu des
moments très difficiles notamment
l'école qu'est ce qui se passe à l'école
j'ai vu que de l'harcèlement sexuel
de harcèlement physique
c'est à dire il se passer quoi pourquoi
c'est à dire qu'il avait labouré
rotation de la libraire en fait j'avais
la boule au ventre mais tu débutes j'en
parlais pas avec mes parents ouais ce
que j'avais peur et ou à des ondes c'est
ce que tu nous avais honte et peur oui
j'avais plus peur pour aller parce que
je sais que mes parents si je le redis
vont pas laisser ça passait et pour les
représailles et tournoi j'avais très
peur
moi c'est comme ça que je vois les voir
comme ça et un jour j'en ai eu marre et
j'en ai parlé à que les gens éclat stand
social jeu du collège qu'a donc un verre
chez mes parents et donc ils m'ont dit
de faire des démarches allaient déposer
plainte et aux mets tous les jours tu
arrives et tous les jours c'était un
indu vivait un cauchemar dormant
critiquer on frappait tous et
j'avais aussi des amis au collège qui
m'ont qui m'ont assez soutenu qu'ils
sont s'est interposé à ça ça et
franchement c'était très très très très
dur d'aller au collège tu as pensé un
moment dire je vais plus au collège je
veux plus j'ai envie d'un moment je me
rappelle il ya dix jours que vous avez
bien dû très fort vous avez dit ma vie
est foutue alors que tu es très jeune
j'ai déjà j'ai mangé j'ai jamais passe à
me suicider personnellement mais j'ai vu
j'ai jamais voulu
couper les veines utile et ouais très
clairement j'étais bel écran jt or
dehors de mon quartier j'y étais avec
une patte et oui j'en ai marre j'étais
en pleurs et où j'étais moi je peux plus
vivre ce genre de choses avaient pris un
couteau et je commençais à un truc est
un
évène way et ma guitare hache et de
couteaux mama limite fil de son moral
positif ahmadis épatant de subir ce
genre de choses c'est pas toi de te
faire du mal on le fait déjà assez du
mal et où je vais répondre mais quand tu
portes plainte et que la police y font
rien qui peut m'aider c'est eux-mêmes
ils peuvent même aider
moi j'aimerais bien le nerf et 10
rebonds toi tu prends ça comme à kamp
unis songent personne je suis on ne peut
rien faire mais aujourd'hui on se
rappelle tous deux de cette agression
qui a été extrêmement violente à vous
l'avez vu un certainement suryani vous
l'avez vu également
sandrine aujourd'hui tu as des nouvelles
de 2,7 à faire ça en est où non non j'ai
pas du tout pas du tout à aucune
nouvelle tu sais que ça avance ou pas du
tout de même ça je ne sais pas du tout
dangereux malheureusement oui voilà on a
sa nouvelle ou vraie voix s'est classée
sans suite pas ça moi pour le coup mais
mes affaires et parce que moi ça date
pas d'aujourd'hui que j'ai parlé ne sont
pas classées sans suite d'après mon
avocat et son
sont ucp sont ou ne sont pas vraies
instruction facile à voir je ne sais pas
vraiment mais ça fait quand même des
années que je portais tant que ça fait
comme une fin c'est quand même des
choses lors même pour moi de 2 à chaque
fois aller dire ce qui s'est passé tout
leur yeah yeah tti rtt pas là n'ont rien
rejeté avec charline chapin je pensais
ça exactement alors qu'est-ce qui est ce
que tu as dit marc lynch après ben en
gros à amman a pas posé de questions par
rapport à mon l'agglo sont ahmad j'y
vois là et je vais juste dit que je me
sentais qu'elle voulait voir ma lecture
en fête pour savoir comment j'allais
vraiment on pouvait avancer c'est ça
parce que ben
c'est là on arrive à un stade où je ne
peux plus en fait je peux plus être
tranquille pour moi c'est comme j'ai dit
à ma vie elle est foutue science est bon
non ac c'est vrai c'est malheureux de
lire ça madame en mai du charron
connaître de sarran succès de de sa
frappe et je suis désolé c'est trop
c'est trop je peux plus chez l'humain un
jour ou l'autre je pète un plomb en fait
c'est ça qu'on veut arrêter justement
les jeunes vont jusqu'à se suicider dans
les jeunes vont jusqu'à ce qu'on arrive
mais céder parce que les gens ils se
sentent comme ils sont à plusieurs jeux
quizz on met des gens elle a fait rire
la galerie alors que c'est des merdes en
fait moi je vous le dit démerde toi
élever ses enfants
[ __ ] ils n'ont pas d'éducation ça
c'est pas mon problème ans mes parents
m'ont éduqué il montera pas faire des
choses moi j'ai aujourd'hui commencent
ils étaient tous mes jambes d'antan mais
tape adjudication en fait moi ma vie
c'est ma vie tant problème avec ma vie
j'en ai rien à [ __ ] je vis pour moi
c'est pas lui qui me torcher le cul
temps chochotte ont fait désolé d'être
comme ça mais ça me saoule en fait là ça
ça me saoule ça me passe par les 118
carrément